Hello Freak bitches.
When do we get a lot of shit happened
on that fuck on that last wild boys trip
man,
there was a that we always,
we had this practice of like,
um,
for the sensors,
you know,
like it's called standards and practices.
There'll be like,
you know,
they'll give back notes,
like you can't,
you know,
show this.
And so we would film what
we call red herrings.
Like we just blatantly ridiculous
shit is never liked it.
Never going to be allowed on TV.
But then we'll be like,
okay,
well we'll cut this out and so then
we'll be able to keep some other shit.
So we would always go out of my way
to fill in this fucked up stuff.
And,
and Russia,
we,
um,
me and one of the guys from the,
from the crew would put like
put on these animal suits.
The,
um,
what was it at the time,
it wasn't panda bears with polar bears
with a big fucking like mascot head.
We fucking hired two hookers and had
full on fucking hookers came in like full
porno.
We felt full fucking porn and we included
to be included that in the episode,
you know,
I had the notes came back
from standards and practices.
I can really please,
I got that you have to take out the,
you know,
the Cock cocksucker yeah.
The polar bear getting his dick
sucked the whole thing and yeah.
And,
and there was,
there was a little bit of fucking
hooker action in that one,
you know,
and I'm not necessarily
that stoked about it,
but,
um,
there was a,
we went to,
we went to like a,
a whorehouse brought this,
um,
hook her back to the hotel.
Right.
He's there like a whole thing.
And then in,
in,
in the,
and I don't think I ever could,
you didn't have sex with a,
with a hooker without like snuggling
after I want to like Snot a snuggle and
shutting it down.
I got in and to stay with me,
I want to like,
you know,
cuddle and stuff.
And in the morning,
this,
this hooker,
um,
she just tells me like,
how much,
how much I owe her,
and I'm like,
that's fucking outrageous.
There's no fucking way.
I was,
I had,
so I was like,
basically,
I don't care if you're a fucking pimp,
wants to kick my ass and fucking kill me.
I'm not paying that fucking much much.
I for,
I forget it was so long ago,
but uh,
but yeah,
I was outraged.
I was,
was how she did it just,
it just wasn't in that case.
I exactly.
I remember clearly I was like,
you,
you want that mentioned I said,
I said,
I'll give you this much and
that's how much he get period.
And we,
we,
we came out,
right?
They got,
you know,
I got to go film and a
walking through the lobby,
Knoxville is down there having breakfast.
This hooker comes walking
by Knoxville and she says,
that's not steevo that's achievable
when
you're faced with a bunch of different
alternative theories that are coming in
and it's not,
it's like take,
take physics.
I mean,
every physicist like you
just had Lawrence Krauss,
he gets these letters
daily of people saying,
I think I figured out why Einstein was
wrong and he can't address them all.
And they're smart people.
They're thoughtful people.
They really believe it.
What do you do with that?
That's my point.
I feel that's not my problem.
And if there are alternative,
the other alternative theories,
that's not my problem either.
It's the problem for the mainstream
to sort it out and figure which to pay
attention to and which,
right.
Well,
I'm suspicious of this,
the whole idea of the mainstream,
because even looking in the mainstream,
you find so many divergent
points of view that I,
you know,
I think that's basically a fiction
that there is this mainstream that has
arrived at this consensus and that there
are no alternative ulterior motives
there.
Um,
and that there are no dogmas
that are being perpetuated there.
You know,
I mean,
I look at the lot of the
geological stuff and,
and realize that there are many different
points of view when we talk about the,
these floods at the end
of the last ice age.
There are many divergent points of view.
There is what could be considered the
mainstream yet even that has multiple
interpretations.
And the same with this,
the comment idea.
Um,
you know,
I mean,
I don't know what constitutes
the mainstream Nair because
there had been a group
that has opposed it at every turn,
but at the same time,
the group that accepts the comment
hypothesis has continued to grow.
In fact,
there's even a number of,
of individuals involved that
set out specifically to,
to disprove it or discredit it,
who are now basically on board.
And it has grown from being a small
handful of scientists that are now 63
scientists from 55 different institutions
that are on board with the idea that
something remarkable happened
at the end of the last ice age.
It was probably exogenic
meaning something from outside,
um,
something from space.
There's no consensus as
to exactly what that was,
which would be normal because the,
these discoveries are in
their infancy at this point.
But there has been an attempt to discredit
the idea simply because that as the
evidence has come in over the last decade,
it has evolved in,
in new mysteries had been opened up.
Uh,
as the evidence comes in
and the claim is being made,
well,
there's no consistent,
um,
interpretation of this evidence
and therefore we've debunked it.
Yeah,
that's a really important
lesson for parenthood.
Like you can't just tell kids what to do,
you know,
like you just do it.
Cause I told you to do it.
They're like,
fuck you,
I'm going to be a hooker.
That's in that,
and that applies not only
to kids and you're 100%,
it applies to kids,
but it applies to adults as well.
And that is people need to understand
why they're doing what they're doing.
And you know,
if I want you to go take down some
building and capture some bad guy,
I don't go,
hey,
hey Joe,
I want you to go take down this
building once you pack captures bad guy,
these are the guys I want
you to take with you.
Here's the route I want you to take in.
Here's the methodology I want
you to use for the clearance.
Because then when I send
you to go do that mission,
it's not your mission.
It's my mission.
I came up with a plan you didn't.
So you might be,
you might have thought there was a
better way to do it or you might had a
different idea of how to get it done.
And now when you go out there and
you meet some kind of resistance,
whether it's an obstacle you didn't
expect or whether it's some scenario you
didn't foresee,
instead of you're trying to overcome it,
you just blame me.
You just looked mad jack who came up
with this stupid plan and here we are.
It's failing.
Forget it.
We're going back.
We're not going to carry out the mission.
Whereas if I said,
hey Joe,
here's what I want you to do,
go figure out the best way to do it.
And now you come up with a plan and now
you make up all the methodologies of how
you're going to get it done and you
decide who you're going to take with you.
Now what's your plan?
You own that plant and when you go
out in the field and you meet a little
resistance,
guess what you do?
You say,
I'm going to find a way around it.
I'm going to overcome this.
I'm gonna overcome that obstacle.
I'm gonna make it happen.
And that's another piece of leadership.
And it's the exact same thing with kids.
If you tell your kid,
you know,
you will get good grades in school,
that means nothing to them.
But if you explain to them,
Hey,
I would love for you to get good
grades and here's why it's gonna open
opportunities for you in the future.
It's going to allow you to be able to
outsmart people cause you're gonna have
more knowledge than them.
And then you're gonna be able
to end up making more money,
which is actually gonna give you
more freedom in the long run.
Instead of doing a job
that you don't want to do.
If you explain all those things to a kid,
it's going to be a lot
more successful than just,
dude,
I told you get good
grades because I said so.
Now when you do these conferences
where when you speak it at,
uh,
businesses and they bring you in
to sort of have these leadership,
uh,
media,
what would you call them?
Yeah,
their leadership seminars.
Seminars.
Yeah.
Now when you have these seminars or these,
uh,
some of the principles that you
discuss when you talk about absolutely.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Because that's another,
another big piece of this is that all
this ideas about interacting with human
beings,
they just don't change.
Like there's a little variance,
but whether you're dealing with kids or
whether you're dealing with adults and
whether you're dealing
with business people,
whether you're dealing with
soldiers on the battlefield,
the leadership principles,
they don't change.
And therefore you can,
whether you're trying to get people to
go out and capture and kill a bad guy,
or whether you're trying to get them
to build some product and sell it,
the principal's leadership don't change.
Do,
you're still trying to get a bunch
of totally independent people.
Right.
And that's one of the myths we have to
overcome a lot because everyone thinks,
oh,
in the military wounds just like a robot.
And that's just not true.
Everybody in the military is free.
There are people,
they're people,
they're free thinking people,
and they're gonna come
up with their own ideas.
They're going to have
with their own agendas,
and they're going to think of ways to do
things that they think are better than
yours.
So you can have all these
independent free thinkers,
and you've got to get them on board
with the same plan to you to go out and
execute.
And so it doesn't matter if you're
on the battlefield or in business.
That's what,
that's what you're trying to get done.
And the leadership
principles don't change.
Okay.